so
two ways of moving one is that my body
is kind of independent that's the
problem my body is independent of what
my hand is doing so when I want my hand
to travel in the upward distance away
from the mat and my body acts
independent it looks like that the
problem is the problem is not and what
to bring my hand moved out so here i am
to say to stay my hand is moving
independently of my body same exact same
exact to say the great girls what are
they I'm doing is I'm going to
coordinate I want my hand go up and I'm
going to make a relationship between my
whole body and that desire to raise my
friend there's a coordination and
actually no independence so I'm on my
hand to go up oh my hand will rise and
it will feel to the user bye I didn't
look this is so obviously felt you'll
feel it in here because that's the
muscle that I'm using to raise my head
on the other one you don't feel that and
fact the harder he pushes the less i'll
feel it really push it feels like he
moved my hand you get that so he's
pushing really hard you're gonna oh man
that was way more deltoid for me when i
coordinate my body the more he pushes he
who he ends up sending himself forward
so I'm gonna do a coke you noggin so you
got to be alive I do like this see
but what happened all that energy that
came you're fighting it you're not
blending tonight but it keeps me out run
into that and get projected off with his
own Fork so he goes in you can't do that
on the other one okay so back to this
here i am and i want to fit to travel
across the map this kind of linear rusty
just my body acting independently and i
just shooting it out i'm tagging fins of
sharks in the nineteen seventies on my
body is going to sin there is the engine
is not in the stick it's certainly not
in my hands it's in the communion of my
intention to thrust alright hit my
target to win the fight and the
coordination of my body to move the
stick that way so if i come back to your
question is there ever a time when you
would just have a shot and as I was
saying of what the better your skill is
you can start to tell the difference
even on so I'm going to hit okay and
you're going to see this that's just
that's just my hand just my hand is okay
and you can you below that looks okay
yes ah then you're going to see oh look
you get his show
hips right and there's a body fusion
that happened that's happening right but
remember what it was it was independence
independence versus soon it wasn't a
size of the movement so you can I hear
it tears my hand right oh my body oh but
this too is my boat this too is my buddy
you go a little trick for you okay say
it's my hand that's my hand that's money
okay and here I I'm not I'll trying to
do no movement with anything but the
movement is in sight so it's not the
size of it it's whether it's separated
whether it is okay so your task is deshi
dealing with body art but i think it is
amplified the problem is greater with
the joke meaning it is easier to swing
this joke without your body meaning
united and because it's easier if you
overcome that disciple and choose not to
do that you will be greater if you
understand how to Lucas turn the right
okay so here's here we go so I go and
this is my body
oxide this is my hands my body is just
totally in the pic it's a platform for
for my shoulders
here's my body you can see it's going to
move it's going to be some movement and
it can be very subtle and the better
your eye is the better you can see you
will have made in your skill acquisition
yourself accustomed to one thing over
another so that what is wrong this looks
wrong you're an American citizen living
in California you have been cultured and
when someone is just so far out of that
culture or someone says something so far
you don't know right away by that just
attention-grabbing to you it's because
you need so you're trying to train
yourself in this culture so that just
we're trying to understand here why did
it look weird phul the body is
independent of the ok so here's my body
you can start to see that I'm moving my
body things of the technique
okay well I'm exaggerating and some
who's allowed for more body movement in
other moves so if we pick up where we
left off this move this move allows for
very little body but it doesn't mean I
don't have any doesn't mean I go like
this the this move is closer to that
finger punch your power comes from
inside right not risk flip but it's all
just in there see that so we go it's got
a hit from in okay alright so the drill
without and to set me up more for
success boom okay here when I move this
line over here and I'm off my body let's
just wait if you hear if you have that
subtle lot you can chill if you have
that subtle I what what am I already
doing which way am i leaning
I'm I'm laying in this way come come
look behind me Chris you see you see
that why why am i doing that what if I
lean straight i'm gonna fall right why
am I going to fall okay the way to the
joe what's the blood crazed angle of
disturbance okay so can you see it i AMA
shukaku over yet okay and that's where
i'm sticking the weapon what happens is
if everyone goes so quick and they don't
give a damn if they don't ever ask is
this pen easy logically sound okay and
the way the artworks 50 it's an easy
logically unsound it's also probably
tactically unsound okay did you give up
the center line yeah you did so let's
set it up just in terms of geometry if I
want to create an address deflection on
his weapon I have to hit the front of
proportion of this Joe if I hit the
upper portion of this Joe even though I
knock it down this weapon is still going
to come this way but it's there if i hit
the front porch in the very flat portion
of this job you're going to have a clash
so we go do the same thing that is where
i want to hit it alright when do I want
to hit it there when do I want to hit it
there if his weapon breaks this
90-degree angle it is going to come
through okay it's also not going to be a
stopped it meaning that you're hitting
it as it's starting to enter into power
cycle you need to kill it back here ok
so it never gets out there when you do
that you don't have to move your
weapon off the line to the tenth degree
and you might not even have to adjust
your foot and keep your balance okay and
that's going to allow me to keep the
joke on my center line which is going to
allow me to unify it to that internal
organization okay because this is not
going to allow me to do it I'm following
and I'm leaning and I can't generate
power through the ground when I'm
followed and leaning like that so I go
Phil be hidden it's right here boom
right here so I don't have to do any
foot adjustment and I am now in this
drill is just hit it with his Joe got
already contact by the 90 and now i'm
just going to flex and put my weight in
my hands boom down lose his weapon right
there drop the body alignment oh hey try
that so what is that what is that
technique with that body unity it's
putting you know colloquially we say put
your weight in your hand okay so here we
go he's trying to lift my hands and this
is me not using my mud I'm tasked myself
with something the first task must lift
your hand away from the earth the second
task is move your hand towards the Earth
so here I am okay he lifts and I'm going
to organize my body lift lift
yo meticulously once I Morgan I keep
looking you can stand up what's up
organized you're going to see that I
have this kind of log here it's in it's
in here it's not in here you're not
doing this stuff so I'm going to giving
it really tired because i'm going to
talk for a while and what you have the
organization is starting here then you
can relax you can relax stay connected
they can relax the hand is is always in
this heaviness 70s stay connected say
maybe 50 sleep every time it snow
different when I put the Joe in my time
when I want that darkness put weight in
my hands organize my body for that house
joy does that look right yeah it's the
same thing wait in my hands okay
where where should the weapon remain
between you right you and me this I'm
not fighting safe let's fight someone
over there that would be pretty good
once you feel the year you don't go past
you don't fall out it's me see then
that's right I did my body works okay
and part of the problem when you just
swing the stick is you can't feel the
again you can't feel the young and
you're plagued by inertia swinging the
weapon and the weapons going to whoa and
what everyone tends to do is they flex
this little weapon that this week they
were actually started slowing down over
there but if you put your weapon out of
the target and I'm moving from my Center
the weapon can go full speed and snap
it'll stop it's no different than here
stick your weapon up like you're doing
on come on the sword and I hit it hit my
savings that concept so what's happening
is when you coming around you're
swinging it and just whoa and then
you're going to try to come back if you
throwing it out with your body boom
it'll just stop right there it'll be
ready hope we talked about
culture where I can see what needs to be
seen and starts to look weird where I'm
not seeing okay so this is an obvious
example my body is totally unrelated
okay and try to lift the hand so he's
lifting the Hat and this is an obvious
example that shoulder is independent of
the rest of my life what's not so
obvious all the subtle things that
you're doing the gross thing do what
it's doing okay so we he's pushing and I
want to task myself with lifting the
hand again so if you watch right there's
going to be a weight shift there's going
to be a knee bend just going to be a
pelvic tilt there's going to be a kind
of coiling in that elbow will move in
the laughs we'll move forward and in and
there the back is going to stretch in
the upper part of my body because I have
to inhale before I can exhale okay so
he's pushing and you look for this so
they're deep in the weight shift the
pelvis oh and once you have the yen cool
and you can do the yard oh the exact
opposite of all those energy so nine out
of ten times or majority of the time
when you integrate the body the back
foot has to be engaged with the earth
when the back foot is flying around like
that you're not doing okay
so here we go p skis all right back foot
is in the air at the moment we're impact
would have happened watch it again see
that so the back foot could not act as
the projection point for they output a
force it's not doing that you're not
doing that you're doing rotational
movement that's all you have okay and
that's different because you have
mistaken the circle for a circle or it
probably wasn't it and your art is not
very superficial and unsophisticated and
if you look you're just a scientist of
motion I am actually solid link on the
outside you see that what we do is we
hide it I hit it I moved out well I do
have any power I didn't really thrive in
half there's no power on the strike
you'll see your collection right
back foot is engaged until I realize you
he finally now I just engage in go to
motion whoa the back foot is engaged do
I realize oh no see this point not on it
oh here we go again back what is it go
to be engage ya can't be off can't be
off here but what is all obviously off
obviously off but so is this this is too
much weight here my body's back you
dirty right that is the in movement to
that absorbs it and takes away the class
so go back around your head so he's
going around I reach and I'm here you
see that that little movement is
stopping my straight from being hit by
his stick will be my tiny bit night of
it come around that's the same movement
where my pelvis can't let when I'm here
like this it's very hard to flex my cup
of tea okay that is now where I can do
that a job move it because I did the yen
move it pull
very common mistake is you can
emotionally / invest it in the target
and it tends to generate a gravity and
the gravity pulls you in and when you
get pulled in you lose awareness of the
bigger picture so let's switch roles and
go on and you're here all right and some
people will gravitate into the target
you and that's why you have a weapon
okay you want to be at the maximum
weight you can be to hit the web take
the target so watch that you're not
Spoony then right if this leads to
retention issues it leads to be having
more options okay so as we do the switch
holes again then I'm out here no no
don't get pulled into the target it's
the same thing when we do the weapons to
people want to kiss the guy with the end
of the handle that's what do you have a
handgun you don't have to kiss him with
the end of it you shoot him right so the
same thing here don't get pulled in oh
you just want to be right where I have a
margin for error he moves backward or
forward I'm still gonna hit ya I don't
need that bunch of a margin fair you
guys copy that okay okay try it again